ليه الحديث عن كل ذلك وهذا الملف ملف
الحرب المتواصله في اوكرانيا معي في سوريا
خالد الغرابي اهلا بك خالد اا بالتالي
نتوقف عند تصريحات البروتين الاخيره حول
الاسلحه المتطوره وان كل صراع ينتهي
باتفاق هل هي رغبه في التصعيد ام استعداد
لتحقيق السلامه
الرئيس الروسي قال انه في النهايه كل
النزاع مسلح ينتهي بنوع من انواع الاتفاق
وزير الدفاع هيتحدث ان روسيا منفتح على
عقد اتفاق لكن في الوقت نفسه هو همم سمعنا
الرئيس الروسي يتحدث عن ادخال الاسلحه
حديثه ومتطوره جدا يقول حتى هناك صواريخ
ليس لها مثيل في العالم ستدخل الخدمه
قريبا همم هذا معناه عندما يتحدث عن اتفاق
بدون ان يحكي يتحدث يحدد شروطه للوصول الى
هذا اتفاق هذا معناها لم يصل بعد الى ان
يحصل على هذه الشروط وسمعنا تصريحات من
مسؤولين روسيا يقولون ان زياره زنيسكي الى
الولايات المتحده بعدها لم يسمع شيء يوضح
ان هناك تفهم لحاجات روسيا اذا
بالنسبه للروز على الامور لم تنضج بعد
الوصول الى اتفاق وبالتالي الان الرساله
الروسيه اننا مستعدون للاستمرار في هذه
الحرب حتى نحصل على ما نريد وان كان في
النهايه ما نريده والوصول الى اتفاق طيب
كيف سنستمر في هذه الحرب ونسمع جميعا
سمعنا الانتقادات التي وجهت الى قدرات
الجيش الروسي في هذه المعركه
الروسيا الرئيس الروسي تحديدا يريد ان
يظهر نفسه وعمليه يقرب انها كانت هناك
اخطاء عندما يتحدث يقول ان الطائرات بدون
طيار لا بد ان توصل الرسائل بشكل مشفر وفي
الوقت الفعلي لسائر المعركه هذا معناه ان
لم تكن تفعل ذلك من قبل عندما يقول انه
يجب تحسين قدرات القياده والسيطره عندما
يقول انه يجب زياده قدرتنا على الرد على
مدفعيه العدوه ضروره الاهتمام اكثر بتقديم
الخدمات الصحيه وكل ما يتعلق همم تقديم
الغذاء حتى الملابس حتى على المستوى الزي
العسكري لا جهود المشاركين في المعارك هذا
معناه انه قام بعمليه النقد وجرد لنقاط
الضعف التي تمت يقر بها
ويعمل على تحسينها وهذه الرساله ربما
للغرب الذي كان يقول ان الروس دخلوا
المعركه
وهموم بانهم لديهم قدره عسكريه كبيره
لكنها الواقع بين غير ذلك هو يقول اننا
نعيما لدينا من مشاكل ونعمل على اصلاحها
وهذا الذي سيسمح لنا بالاستمرار بالاضافه
طبعا
لان سنقدم كل ما يحتاجه الجيش في المرحله
المقبله وزير الدفاع حتى يكمل هذه الرساله
بالقول انه سيتم اعاده هيكله الجيش بانه
سيتم همم زياده خلقه وحدات جديده وسيتم
زياده عدد الجنود بنحو 30,000 جنيه لتصل
الى نحو مليون ونصف المليون جنيه في
النهايه اذا ما يقول الروس نحن نستعد
لمعركه طويله الامد حتى نحصل على ما
نريد حتى الان لن نحصل عليه وطبعا هذا ما
يقوله همم نتذكر في السابق ان اا بوتين
كان اا عندما اعاد تنظيم الجيش الروسي قال
انه يستعد لان يكون دوله عظمى ومع ذلك
جاءت التجربه في اوكرانيا راينا محدوديه
فاعليه هذه القوات وبالتالي سننتظر لنرى
حقيقه هل الاصلاحات التي سيعمل الروس على
همم العمل بها ستكون كافيه لان يكون الجيش
الروسي اكثر فعاليه ام نفس الاخطاء ستور
كامله من جديد طيب خالد الامريكيون يقول
انه لا يوجد ما يثبت رغبه موسكو في انهاء
هذا صرع وبالتالي الرغبه في السلام
ويعرضون بمليرات المساعدات لاوكرانيا لما
هي رسالته
في فتره ما كان هدف الامريكيين همم هو
استنزاف القوات الروسيه في هذه الحرب
وروسيا على هنالك همم استمروا في دعم
اوكرانيا وكانوا من مصلحتهم استنزاف
القوات الروسيه لانهم يعلمون ان روسيا خصم
همم يجب اضعافه حتى يكون وضعهم افضل ويتم
الاستفرادته او التركيز على الخصم الاخر
وهو الصيد طبعا همم لكن مع الوقت بدانا
نسمع رسائل مختلفه من قبل الجيش حتى الجيش
الامريكي القول ان ما تم تحقيقه حتى الان
من الجيش الاوكراني شيء جيد لكن المرحله
المقبله باعاده تم وضع القوات الروسيه
واستعدادها ل همم شتاء ربما تطول في الحرب
النتائج ستكون محدوده وبالتالي يجب اغتنام
الفرصه وتحقيق شيء سياسي
يعني يرتكز على ما تم تحقيقه على الارض
هذا خرج من داخل الولايات المتحده ثم نقرا
الان في الصحف الامريكيه كيف ان همم هذه
الحرب هي حرب استنزاف يعني
القوات الاوكرانيه بحسب بعض الخبراء الذين
اعتدوا على مصادر في الاستخبارات وشركات
لتصنيع الاسلحه
تسختم حوالي 40,000 قذيفه شهريا من عيار
155 مللي متر كل ما تنتجه القاره
الاوروبيه في الشهر و25,000 قذيفه وليس
يعني تقريبا نصف يعني تستهزفه اوكرانيا في
همم الشهر وهذا معناه ماذا هذا معناه حق
اولا عجز على تربيه حاجات اوكرانيا على
مدى الطويل والا سيتم اللجوء الى المخازن
ومن يملك القدره بمخازن وفيره الولايات
المتحده لكن افراغ المخازن هي مشكله امنيه
في غايه الاهميه وبالتالي على المدى
الطويل هذه الحرب سيكون لها تابعات ليست
جيده ثم في النهايه همم الى اين ستصل حرب
على قوه تملك السلاح النووي في لحظه مع
هناك خطر المواجهه النوويه وبالتالي يجب
على الولايات المتحده ان تعرف متى ستصل
الى ان تدفع الاوكرانيين للوصول الى سلام
وربع سيكون زياده للولايات المتحده ما حدث
في الكواليس له علاقه بهذا الامر لان
بلنكنا اليوم يتحدث عن ان رؤيه زنسكي
للسلام التي تم بحثها خلال هذه الزياره
والتي لم يتحدث كثيرا الاعلام عنها هي
تبدو امر جيدا او بدايه جيده واتحدث لينكن
عن ضروره الوصول الى سلام عادل ومستقر
ماذا يعني السلام عادل ومستقر بالنسبه
لتفسير الامريكي قال انه بالنسبه لعادل
يعني لا نقبل او لن لن نوافق على
الدوله على اراضي دوله اخرى بالقوه يعني
ضروره انسحاب القوات الروسيه الى اي ماده
لم يدخل في التفاصيل ثم ماذا يعني مستقر
يعني انه يجب ان تصل اوكراني الى وضعي
يمنع الرئيس الروسي من اعاده التجربه بعد
اشهر وبعد عام يعني دعم اوكرانيا بشكل
معين الان ال- ال- الاوكرانيين او
الاوكرانيون كانوا يريدون سحاب بروسي كامل
قبل الوصول الى السلام الى اي مدى هذا
طبعا روسيا يرفضون ذلك تماما هم ضموا
اربعه
مناطق في الشرق ويعتبرونها اراضي روسيا
اذا تبدوا الامور من الناحيه اا المبدئيه
للتفاوض معقده جدا لكن الامريكيين همم
يتحدثون الان عن بدايه جيده من الجانب
الاوكراني لا يعرف الكثير وبمواذات ذلك كل
طرف يحاول ان يدعم اوراقه قبل الوصول الى
طاوله المفاوضات ومن هنا كان هناك حرس من
الجانب الامريكي يعني الاعلان عن هذه
المساعدات نحو همم 50 مليار طبعا ننتظر
موافقه الكونغرس عليها وهمم اهميه زياره
ربما للوحه المتحده هو ان يضمن ان جمهوريه
سادعمون هذه استمرار هذه المساعدات لانه
همم تحول
ان هو الى جمهوريين وهناك قيادات من
الجمهوريين تعارض تقول لماذا ننفق كل هذه
المليارات على صراع بعيد كل هذا البعض عن
حدود الامريكيه الشعب الامريكي اولا كان
يريد ان يتاكد من استمرار هذا الدعم
والامريكيون ربما كان يريدون ان يعرفوا
الى متى ستستمر هذه الحرب وفرص الوصول الى
السلام مع ازيسكي
ووصلوا الى ان يعدوا بهذه الحزمه من
المساعدات ومنها منظومه
فعاله بالاساس هي نظام دفاعي همم لا يعرف
بالضبط عدد الوحدات التي ستسلم الى
اوكرانيا ربما تكون حسب الارقام المعلنه
مليار و800 مليون نحن نتحدث على ما يقرب
من وحده واحده مع بعض الذخيره هذا طبعا لن
يكون كافي لتغيير مسار الحرب ثم ان همم
بالاساس هذه المنظومه هي للدفاع عن ضد
الصواريخ الباريسيه وربما الطائرات لكن
الطائرات المصريه تخيل ان تتخذني صاروخ
تكلفه ما بين ثلاثه الاربعه ملايين باسقاط
طائره مسيره ايرانيه بعده الاف الدولارات
طبعا النتيجه هي خساره لكن سنرى مدى
فعاليه هذا تبدو حتى الان الامور محدوده
لكن الرساله الامريكيه
سنستمر في الدعم حتى الوصول الى سلام شروط
السلام ربما بعثت في الكواليس مع زينيسكي
لكن لم يعلن كثيره جزيلا الشكر لك خالد
الغرب على هذه القراءه التحليليه شكرا
جزيلا لك